♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
AN HOUR FROM RIGHT NOW THE
VICE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE BEGINS
IN SALT LAKE CITY UTAH.
IT IS A LEGITIMATE NEWS EVENT,
OBVIOUSLY, BUT WE ARE GOING TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU, UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES WE WOULDN’T GIVE
IT EXACTLY BREATHLESS COVERAGE.
IT’S NOT THAT INTERESTING.
NOTHING ABOUT THE VICE
PRESIDENCY IS VERY INTERESTING.
QUICK, HOODED HILLARY CLINTON
RUN WITH FOUR YEARS AGO?
IF YOU GUESSED SOME GUY, YOU’RE
SQUARELY IN THE MAJORITY OF MOST
AMERICANS.
DON’T FEEL BAD ABOUT IT, HISTORY
BARELY REPORTS THE NAME OF
WINNING VP CANDIDATES.
IT’S FAIR TO SAY THAT
ABRAHAM LINCOLN WAS A PRETTY BIG
DEAL.
HE ENDED SLAVERY AND WON THE
CIVIL WAR, BUT HOW MANY PEOPLE
REMEMBER LINCOLN’S FIRST
VICE PRESIDENT, HANNIBAL HAMLIN
OF PARACEL MAIN?
EVEN IN MAINE THERE ARE SOME WHO
HAVE NEVER HEARD OF HIM.
NELSON ROCKEFELLER BECAME
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNIT IT
STATES UNDER GERALD FORD.
WHAT YOU DO ALL DAY, SOMEONE
ONCE ASKED HIM.
"I GO TO FUNERALS," HE SAID.
I GO -- THAT WAS A FAIR
DESCRIPTION.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
DICK CHENEY, EVERY MODERN
VICE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN UTTERLY
SUBORDINATE TO THE LEADER HE HAS
SERVED.
MOST VICE PRESIDENT’S ARE
AFTERTHOUGHTS AND THAT WAS
ESPECIALLY TRUE OF JOE BIDEN.
BARACK OBAMA HAD SUCH A LOW
OPINION OF JOE BIDEN’S
INTELLIGENT IN HIS ABILITIES
THAT HE OPENLY MOCKED HIM TO HIS
STAFF, TWICE.
OBAMA REFUSED TO ENDORSE
JOE BIDEN FOR PRESIDENT,
PRESUMABLY FOR THE GOOD OF THE
COUNTRY.
WHAT’S INTERESTING AND WHAT’S
SAD IN A WAY, IS THAT YEARS
LATER, JOE BIDEN IS STILL IN THE
SAME ROLE.
IF HE IS ELECTED PRESIDENT,
JOE BIDEN WOULD REMAIN THE
JUNIOR PARTNER IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
BIDEN WILL BE 78 ON
INAUGURATION DAY
INAUGURATION DAY.
IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE HE WOULD
FINISH A FULL TERM, BUT EVEN IF
HE DOES, KAMALA HARRIS IS MORE
THAN 20 YEARS YOUNGER.
SHE IS SHARPER, MORE AGGRESSIVE
AND FAR MORE IN TUNE WITH THE
RADICAL SPIRIT OF THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
KAMALA HARRIS KNOWS WHAT SHE
WANTS, NO QUESTION.
SHE BULLDOZED HER ELDERLY
SENTIMENTAL BOSS.
SO TONIGHT WE WILL BE AIRING THE
VICE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE, WHAT
WE WILL ACTUALLY BE LOOKING AT
IS KAMALA HARRIS ’S AUDITION FOR
THE PRESIDENCY.
THAT’S THE OFFICE SHE’S RUNNING
FOR, NO MATTER WHAT THEY TELL
YOU.
THE DEBATE ITSELF WILL LOOK
WEIRDER THAN MOST OF THEM DO.
HARRIS AND MIKE PENCE WILL BE
SEPARATED ON STAGE BY SHEETS OF
PLEXIGLAS LIKE THE CHECKOUT
COUNTER AT AN INNER-CITY LIQUOR
STORE.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN DEMANDED THIS
THIS.
ACTUAL SCIENTISTS LAUGHED AT IT,
THERE’S NO MEASURABLE HEALTH
BENEFIT TO DOING IT, BUT
WHATEVER.
THIS OF THE SAME PEOPLE WHO WEAR
THEIR MASKS WHEN THEY RIDE THEIR
BICYCLES, THEY ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN WHAT SCIENCE SAYS.
THEY WANT TO LOOK SERIOUS.
ONE THING THEY ARE REALLY
SERIOUS ABOUT THOUGH IS IDEOLOGY
IDEOLOGY.
THEY’RE NOT KIDDING.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS AN AGENDA, A
REAL ONE.
A CLOSE LOOK AT WHAT SHE WOULD
DO AS OUR FUNCTIONAL PRESIDENT.
THOSE DETAILS HAVEN’T BEEN MUCH
DISCUSSED IN THE MEDIA, YOU HAVE
MAY HAVE NOTICED, MOST THE COVER
TRIBES CENTERED ON QUESTIONS
LIKE HOW DO YOU SAY HER NAME?
BY THE WAY, JOE BIDEN STILL
DOESN’T KNOW, HE REGULARLY MISS
PRONOUNCES IT.
MOST OF THE REST OF THE COVERAGE
OF PARIS IS CONSISTED OF WARNS
THAT WE HAD BETTER GO EASY ON
HER.
KAMALA HARRIS IS A WOMAN.
IN A CRITICISM WILL BE REGARDED
AS SEXIST.
TO BE CLEAR, NOT AS SEXY, BUT
AS SEXIST, WHICH IS BAD.
>> HER TEAM IS ALSO AWARE OF THE
UNFAIR GENDER STEREOTYPES THAT
SHE MIGHT BE UP AGAINST.
A SECRETARY HILLARY CLINTON
ADVISING SENATOR HARRIS TO BE
ASSERTIVE, TO BE FIRM, BUT ALSO
TO NOT DO SO TOO STRONGLY AS TO
BE SEEN AS AGGRESSIVE.
UNFAIR, TO BE SURE, BUT THAT’S
THE ADVICE COMING FROM THE FIRST
FEMALE NOMINATED TO BE A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE FOUR
YEARS AGO.
>> Tucker: GENDER STEREOTYPES.
WHATEVER MSNBC DIDN’T BOTHER TO
EXPLAIN IS HOW IN A WORLD WHERE
WE ARE REQUIRED TO PRETEND THAT
GENDER CATEGORIES ARE REAL, HOW
IN THAT WORLD CAN GENDER
STEREOTYPES EVEN EXIST?
WHAT EXECUTIVES THAT MEAN?
IT DOESN’T MEAN ANYTHING,
OBVIOUSLY, IT’S NOT A
DESCRIPTION, IT’S A THREAT.
LEAVE KAMALA HARRIS ALONE OR WE
WILL HURT YOU.
WE WILL SMEAR YOU AS A BIGOT IF
YOU ATTACK HER, GOOD LUCK
GETTING A JOB AFTER WE’RE DONE.
HARRIS HERSELF HAS DONE THIS
MANY TIMES.
SHE’S A SEASONED PRO AT HIDING
BEHIND HER OWN IDENTITY.
LAST FALL FOR EXAMPLE, POLLS
SHOWED HER LOSING HER HOME STATE
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
THAT’S PRETTY EMBARRASSING.
BUT HARRIS HAD AN EXPLANATION
FOR IT.
CALIFORNIA IS RACIST.
AMERICANS IN GENERAL ARE RACIST,
THAT’S WHY THEY DON’T LOVE ME.
>> WHAT I’VE DESCRIBED IN WHAT I
BELIEVE TO BE IN THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM ABOUT MY CAMPAIGN.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> ELECTABILITY.
ESSENTIALLY, IS AMERICA READY
FOR A WOMAN AND A WOMAN OF COLOR
TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> AMERICA WAS READY FOR A BLACK
MAN TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> IN THIS CONVERSATION HAPPENED
FOR HIM.
THERE IS A LACK OF ABILITY OR A
DIFFICULTY IN IMAGINING THAT
SOMEONE WHO WE HAVE NEVER SEEN
HIM DO A JOB THAT HAS BEEN DONE
45 TIMES BY SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
THAT PERSON.
>> Tucker: YEAH, A LOT OF
RACIST DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS
OUT THERE.
THE WEIRD THING IS, ALL OF THESE
SECRET RACIST DEMOCRATS VOTED
FOR BARACK OBAMA TWICE IN A ROW.
THAT’S PRETTY STRANGE BEHAVIOR
FOR RACISTS.
BABY IT’S HARRIS ’HAS INDIAN
SIDE THEY OBJECT TO.
OR MAYBE THE WHOLE EXPLANATION
IS A LUDICROUS CROCK OF NONSENSE
DOESN’T EVEN MAKE SENSE.
MORE LIKELY, VOTERS DON’T LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS BECAUSE SHE IS A
TRANSPARENT FRAUD, FROM HER
PHONY INFLECTED ACCENT, HER
SYNTHETIC BIO, TO HER
FEATHERWEIGHT WORK HISTORY.
JOE BIDEN’S CORN POP STORY IS
MORE REAL THAN ANYTHING ABOUT
KAMALA HARRIS AND IT’S NOT EVEN
TRUE.
DEMOCRATIC POLLSTERS KNOW ALL
THIS, THEY SEE THE NUMBERS, AND
THAT’S WHY THEY’VE TOLD HARRIS
TO START USING THE PHRASE
"SPEAKING THE TRUTH."
MAYBE VOTERS WILL THINK SHE IS.
>> ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
VALUES I THINK WE MUST FIGHT FOR
A SPEAKING THE TRUTH.
>> WE HAVE TO SPEAK TRUTH ABOUT
IT.
>> WE SPEAK TRUTH AND WE ARE
LOYAL.
>> THAT WE SPEAK TRUTH.
>> LET’S SPEAK TRUTH.
>> LET’S SPEAK ANOTHER TRUTH.
>> WE MUST ALL SPEAK TRUTH.
>> SELECT SPEAK SOME TRUTH.
>> AND WE NEED TO SPEAK THAT
TRUTH SO WE CAN DEAL WITH IT.
>> LET’S SPEAK ANOTHER TRUTH,
LET’S SPEAK TRUTH ABOUT OUR
ECONOMY AND LET’S SPEAK THE
BIGGEST TRUTH, THE BIGGEST TRUTH